hello and welcome i'm james murphy from m coding
and today we're talking about the single most
important feature coming soon in python 3.10 i'm
talking about structural pattern matching and the
match statement depending on when you're watching
this video python 3.10 might already be out
but at the time of recording which is march 17
2021 python 3.9 is the latest version i just
saw that pep634 on structural pattern matching
was accepted so i had to download my own copy
of the latest branch of python compile it and try
running it for myself as you can see down here in
my python console i am running a version of python
3.10 you can see here the exact git commit hash
of the commit that i'm using so i couldn't wait to
check out this new feature i had to just compile
it myself and i thought i'd make a video about
it so here it is basically in prior versions of
python we already had some very primitive versions
of pattern matching so if i have for example
x comma y i can say x comma y is equal to one
comma two now what does this mean well python
is smart enough to figure out that well this
is a sequence of length 2 and this looks like a
sequence of length 2 so it figures out to assign x
to 1 and y to 2. this new syntax through the match
statement takes it to a whole new level let's
take a look at some examples so all throughout
this video you can look on your left to see the
new syntax and on the right how you would have
to write it or what might be the simplest way to
write it without using the match statement so of
course python is a turing complete language so
the match statement doesn't really add anything
new in terms of what programs can be written what
it adds is a new way to think about programs so
on the left is going to be the new match syntax
and on the right is going to be the old way of
doing it first up we have this function command
split which takes in a command which is let's
say a string we'll do a command split and that
will break up the string into a list of strings
and then we want to do different things based
off of what those things are so you can imagine
this would be useful if you're like writing a
shell just for demonstration purposes i have a
few different commands here so you can see we're
going to match what does this command dot split
look like and then the syntax is you have a match
and then the thing that you want to match and then
a bunch of cases that it could look like so the
way that it works is python will compute this
and then try each case one after another until
it finds a match if it doesn't find a match it's
kind of like an if false where it just wouldn't
execute anything in the body this is similar to
a switch statement but on steroids so you can see
that on the left we have a much more declarative
style than on the right well first off the code
on the right is terrible i mean can anyone look
at this and just read what it's doing probably not
you have to go through every single one and check
you know is the length two and the first one
zero you have to really read every single line
whereas on the left it's a much more declarative
style where you just say this is what it looks
like does it match so let's just slowly go
through a few different cases and then you'll
sort of get the idea of how the match statement
works so in this first case we're matching
a list with one element whose only thing in it is
the word make that's pretty self-explanatory now
technically speaking when you do a match like
this it doesn't have to be a list that you're
matching against it can be any sequence type so if
i passed in a tuple it would still match a list in
the second case we're saying we have a sequence
of two elements the first of which is make
and then we just put in the name of a variable
here similar to the way a for loop works
this cmd does not have to be already defined this
is a name and we are binding whatever value is in
the sequence at that point to this name now if
you read the documentation it is very careful to
always use the word bind rather than assign which
you might you know colloquially think of we're
going to assign the value here to the variable
cmd but for technical reasons it is not actually
assigning the next case is just another single
element restart we've already been over that
this next case is the word rm remove followed by
any number of extra arguments so this is similar
to a star args situation here where there can be
zero or more things here and this files variable
will then be a tuple containing all of those
extra things so you can see on the right hand
side what it's actually doing it's going to be
checking if the length is right if it sees the rm
and then assigning or technically not assigning
but i'm going to slip up and use that word
it's going to be assigning files to whatever
is left and then finally this underscore is the
python way of saying a wildcard anything
so case underscore will match any pattern
so in the comparison with a switch statement this
is kind of like your default case if nothing else
matches then this case will be executed now if i
didn't have this wildcard case here and i passed
in something that doesn't match any of the other
things then just nothing would be printed if it
doesn't match it doesn't execute and you can see
on the right hand side how this compares the wild
card is much like an else so let's go ahead and
just put in some test cases to see what they do
and you know run it to prove that
i actually compiled the python
so you can see command split make we do a make a
make clean a restart remove abc and then something
that doesn't match and you can see we do a
make make clean so we say found command clean
and then a restart and then deleting the files abc
and so you see files was passed here as a list and
then the wildcard statement okay let's move on to
the next example so in the last example we were
matching on a command dot split i just wanted to
put this in so you can see that you can actually
match on a variable itself you don't have to
match on some sub-expression so this is just
almost a simpler example i can match a variable
against certain specific values so in this case
it will check to see if they're equal
by using the equals equals operator
unless of course you're using true false or
none in which case they'll be compared with
the is operator so in this case i think
i might actually prefer the old syntax
and of course if we add in a little use case
here then we can see that it matches the 42.
okay let's move on in this example we see that you
can use the pipe operator to give alternatives for
the same case so in this case i take in a command
and i can either say north or go north and both
of those will have the same effect you can even
do it when you're binding a variable even if the
position of the variable is different from case
to case so you can see in this case i can say
get object or pick up object or pick object up
and all of those will match notice how simple
this syntax is if i wanted to do the exact same
thing this is what it looks like in python 3.9 say
much more complicated on this side much easier to
be read on this side and on the right side we have
code duplication which means a chance for error
especially if something changes in the future
so you can see if i add these two use cases
then both of these match in the expected way
so i said go north and pick up sword this
example is short and sweet but it really
shows off the important feature of structural
pattern matching it's composable in any pattern
i can put another pattern as part of the
pattern so you can see in this case i'm matching
i have a list the first element is go
and the second element is this pattern
so it can be north south east or west so i can say
go north go south go east or go west when i have
alternatives like this i'm not necessarily going
to know which one of that sub-pattern matched
so python also allows you to use this as and
then the name of the variable to capture the
value of that match you can see that with these
test cases see going north going east direction
gets first north and then east this next
example shows off guards in match statements
so this is similar to when you have a list
comprehension you say something for something
in something if and then you give a condition
and it only goes through the elements where that
condition is true so you can have a case and then
say this case only applies if this condition holds
so in this situation you have a command which is
like telling a character which direction to move
and then you're also passing in a list of exits so
if there's an exit on the north but there's a wall
on the east then you can't go to the east you
could only go to the north something like that
so i'll say go direction but only if the direction
is in the set of allowable directions and if i
match something which is go and then here's
the use of a wild card go and then anything
that didn't match this then i just say you can't
go that way so if i give these two examples go
north and go north both times but if the exits
are east and south in the first case and the north
and the second case then we should expect that
it is only able to go north in the second case
and indeed when we don't have a north exit
when we say go north we get can't go that
way but when there is then we get going north
for this next example imagine that we have some
kind of event-driven architecture we're receiving
events and they're getting passed to this function
and our events can be clicks they can
be key presses or it can be a quit event
now you're really going to like this one because
this massively simplifies the code makes it
way easier to read i hope you appreciate how
nice this pattern matching is in this instance
so i take an event and i'm matching
on the event the match statement cases
can use the following syntax you can
put in for a case the name of a class
and you can fill in some of its attributes so
in this case i've filled in the attribute button
and i've given it a value so this case is
matching is the event an instance of the click
class so is it a click whose button is left and
then notice position x y, x and y aren't defined
here so x and y are going to be variables that
get assigned the value of these positions you
might think that this syntax is going to construct
a click and in any other place in python that is
what would happen but specifically inside a match
statement next to a case just like this if you
write what looks like the constructor of
a class what you're actually saying is
match something that is an instance of
that class with those particular attributes
so you can see this case i'll match any
left click this will match any other
click in this case i'm matching a key press
but i'm specifying capital q or lowercase q
as a positional argument not as a keyword argument
like here i'm saying keyname equals up arrow or
here i'm effectively saying keyname is capital
q or lower q if you want to match any instance
of a class you just give it like this with an
empty constructor and finally here this is kind
of another wildcard case except i'm giving a name
to it i'm saying if you reach this case it will
match anything and we'll bind the name other event
to that value now of course i already had access
to the variable event so it's kind of pointless
to give it another name other event but if this
was some kind of asynchronous framework i might do
something like you know event.get at which point
i no longer have access to this as a variable so
this would allow me to capture it at that moment
but for now let's just get rid of that so
here are the test cases for that function
we're going to do a left click at zero zero and
then a quit and then something that doesn't match
so you see we have a left click and then
quitting and then we caught the exception so
it didn't match in the other case now before
we move on i just want to point out again
look how much more readable the left hand
side is compared to the right hand side
even though my syntax highlighting isn't
working properly on the left-hand side
for obvious reasons pycharm doesn't know about
3.10 syntax but still on the left hand side
i can easily read through know what case is
going to be matched and what's going to happen
whereas the right hand side you really just have
to read line by line the last thing that i want to
show off is dictionary matching so let's match
on an event which you should be imagining that
you have some kind of web api and you just got
some json and now you want to act on that json
based off of certain properties of it so you
say what kind of json event does this look like
well if you have a dictionary like object
you can match it as a dictionary you can say
does this thing have a key called transport
with value http and then you can act on that
now it's fine if there are other keys in the
dictionary so i could have transport http
and then some other value floating around
in there it only matches on the things that
are present in this case you can see that we can
have multiple keys multiple values and what this
is saying here with this n which again is not
defined this is like the variable in a for loop
we are going to define it at that moment it's
saying is the key page number present and if so
assign or bind its value to the name n so let's
just add in that test case i'm going to pass in
a get request for the articles page and i want
page 5 and there is some extra info in there
which is not going to affect the match statement
and you can see let me get that article for you
on page five so that's the match statement i know
that they're going to be heavy heavy debates about
where it is most appropriate to use a match
statement you know is this good code style
what is good code style for this you know new kind
of statement there are going to be lots of debates
on when and where it is most appropriate
to use a match statement but i think that
at least we can take away from this video that in
some situations a match statement can take totally
unreadable code and make it readable at a glance
so although i think that the match statement it's
not really necessary as a programming language
feature i do think that it will find its place
in the python community and it will find its use
cases so that's my take on structural pattern
matching the match statement what i think is
going to be the single most important new feature
introduced in python 3.10. let me know if you find
any other interesting uses for the match statement
or even better if you think that there's something
else new in python 3.10 which is even better than
the match statement so i hope you enjoyed this
sneak preview of what's coming ahead in python
3.10 if you like the video don't forget to like
comment and subscribe see you in the next one